[Music]
Stonehenge has been a source of mystery
for thousands of years but this week the
prehistoric monument may have given up
one of its long kept secrets but amongst
the sarsen stones are remains of about
80 or so smaller stones which are
geologically definite local British
scientists say they have evidence that
some of the smaller stones in stone
henges interior came from - quarry's
about 180 miles away in western wales
these so-called blue stones are smaller
than the more familiar pillars of
Stonehenge but they still weigh as much
and while one mystery of Stonehenge may
be answered the question of how those
ancient builders move the stones remains
huge about whether but you know it's the
exceptional monuments and people were to
accept the lengths to build it is it
wrong that I have vacation in Clark
Griswold in my mind I always wanted to
go definitely on my bucket list and the
mystery only deepens now not only we're
not really sure what it's about but we
don't know how they got the stones all
that distance it's extraordinary